and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win we have a half full podcast
today joining us on the computer la he
we went to Dodgers game and we really
enjoyed the Dodgers rowing train on the
Braves Johnny Woodard everybody
I didn't enjoy that up and live from jus
York everybody the King of the Jews
Ari Shaffir we know who they you can't
say it's half full because half of them
is black that's that's [ __ ] and that's
yours
and finally joining us uh he brought his
Lakers Jersey from when he used to play
well the best his grandma used to cream
Matthews cream I'm surprised oh whoa I'm
surprising that gold and say warriors
Jersey Oh have you been killing me for
that and I gotta keep going on record I
am NOT a Golden State Warriors fan it's
all Lakers I just since they're not in
it I gotta [ __ ] with somebody yeah
no I don't choose a Laker fan I am but
just like most Laker fans they're
conveniently warrior fans to know
especially if you're a fat asian guy you
would love the word yeah they fit that
profile for sure for real but see that's
the thing I wanna hate on Golden State
but LeBron couldn't do it you know I'm
saying LeBron couldn't give me enough
and that's the thing not it's not just
this year I go back to three years ago
that the first time that Golden State
beat Cleveland and LeBron couldn't like
literally every time a Broncos out
Cleveland goes on a ten-point run but
Kareem he hurt his hand though
oh that's right yeah can we get into
this to the Pacquiao I might do you
can't come with that now can't come with
that you or your people because people
are he didn't say it he didn't say yeah
that story period if you know that
stories coming out you got a squash that
yo when you know immediately he started
wearing tape around it like
be taped all the way around and in the
first conference yeah yeah that doesn't
I didn't wear once before then but so
sudden so with his hand broke with his
hand broken the 51 point game
no he said it's out Oh perfect
re what any why you lost you're scoring
51 points the broken hand that ain't why
you lost right but he said it happened
right after that though after they lost
that game he punched the ball so well he
only had 40 oh yeah we have 40 points in
the next game yeah he said he punched
the board after that he punched through
the desert why that even makes it worse
the problem with this is like what he
heatedly he literally if it was any
truth to that
he faces humongous lawsuits from betters
because he didn't disclose the injury he
would never do that dude by law they had
that's why they tell you injuries man
cuz people are betting a lot of money on
these games and that's why Pacquiao got
sued like a [ __ ] dude there's
still soon him cuz he lied about the
shoulder and so you can't do that so -
come on be like oh man I had a boo-boo
you're like dude you gay I might do he I
like we had a big discussion on this
thing where he is in the top and I'm
sure people like cool he goes I still
have met 700 we can't talk about it is
that what happens Kareem it's evolved
into screaming after oh no no no but I
just cannot just hear you said 7 where
did you have them re I won't comment and
the Mugsy Manute I know cuz he's not in
my top ten either oh you're no no I'm
sorry I'm sorry
he's not in my top five okay he's in the
second half of my top ten so would that
be eight nine no seven eight nine ish
okay so get a quick question how many
acres are in your top six
all of them no no no okay
my top five is Kareem Chris why don't
you jump in until people get here is
that cool jump in who knows when they're
gonna be here
Kareem jump in my top five yeah
let's our five is Kareem Bill Russell
will't Jordan and in four or five those
in order yeah okay yes you have Jordan
for yes what's behind Kareem Bill Walton
and will yo and I can I can explain how
I put my list together you don't think
because it's a college but huh oh and in
five I always debate between magic and
Kobe like that's my my five guy and
whoever is the loser falls into the next
group with Jerry West Elgin Baylor Shaq
my top [ __ ] know it goes Jordan won a
cream one B then Magic Johnson then Tim
Duncan then Shaq Nobu tassel that just
and you know what it comes down to
or will it comes down to rings at were
you like what those guys have a built
Russell has a bunch ring commode and it
comes down to a competition he didn't
have a to see that's for me I honestly
for me competition is the hardest thing
to factor through generations and that's
why I put it on rings numbers and then
for me the third is the I test with bill
Russell's taking on guys who are like
substitute teaching during the day yeah
but then there's Chuck Taylors right but
the only ice real quick is my good
friend from a rule we've been friends
for a long time Chris Pleasant everybody
how are you buddy I'm good everybody
good to see you
Chris you used to have one of the
greatest gigs of all time ah it was
really sad that it went away cuz it was
such a fun gig you used to work at
Playboy TV and you just show up daily
with just [ __ ] hot naked chicks
constantly that was probably one of the
best jobs that I've ever had in my life
well I actually got paid to do but you
didn't make a lot of money but it was a
great time yeah it was a great time
that's how I felt like yeah I worked at
a strip club I was like I'm broke as
[ __ ] but I'd never been happy but I
never have to go to a strip club yes but
I never had to go to a strip club yeah
yeah yeah that's honestly been like 80%
of my comedy career it's been like money
but I'm having a great time you booked
commercial so I actually just booked one
do you have so fun as I go you probably
just booked to come on I literally just
did a Comcast congratulations
so I can eat for another two three
months I'm happy can we throw up on
screen
Kareem's nike commercial where he just
goes off for 30 seconds can we do that
anyway just do that anyways I love it
Ari
Ari's my dude yeah dude it's uh it's
kind of crazy
what's going on with LeBron I've come to
the conclusion that when you get to that
rarefied air of like Fame like so high
up there that the air is so thin that it
[ __ ] your skull up like if you don't
get enough oxygen to your brain and you
start acting crazy and everybody who
gets there ends up going a little nuts
and I don't care who it is but like the
hand him talking about sewn right knee
and word on his house that never got
proven but it's just like oh I just
gotta get my name out and it's like
you're LeBron James you don't need your
name out no your name is out there right
commercials yeah I don't mind a spy
commercial to make that money by that's
business
you don't have to Dru's it movie out
after the basketball seasons done do you
understand I'm saying it's alright like
people who moved out from basketball
right and now is coming out huh how long
was that how long did that take of issue
man it's one takes you know but
literally that was one of the first
taste but you know how they are on
commercial shoots do they want to take
all day you know saying we probably
started a thousand times even though
that was probably one of the first five
that they you know saying they ended up
using did you use Meisner what is
Meisner the acting technique alright no
Chris say something just give your take
on something uh I think somebody should
draw Tesla bronze okay that's a good
party shot joining us they are thanks
for joining the cream salmon re show ah
they just made it I apparently they
drove in from Fresno is that where you
guys are coming from basically and the
fight nanny how are you guys good good
good what did we miss how much LeBron
have you already talked you think this
is the LeBron show by top ten is
ridiculous you are after here creams top
ten I don't count like when it's
baseball and you talk about who should
be in the Hall of Fame I take away your
steroid years so with basketball players
I won't count your Laker stats so if you
want Kareem it's only as a book yeah
would feed that's the thing though
Kareem is the greatest basketball player
ever on every level like he was the best
high school player ever the best college
player everything
they called dunking a gold head they
made it illegal yeah they made it
illegal that's the thing he had a rule
change like that's part of my thing like
wilt as well they changed the lane
because of will like those players are
trashy kill O'Neal they changed it from
you had to play man-to-man to zone okay
yeah that's why he's in the second part
of my top ten but like wilts numbers you
know 100 points in a game averaging 50
in a season 33 booing a gun Sky's name
like Bill but see my thing is twenty
thirty fifty a hundred years from now
they're gonna be saying about that about
LeBron right now no look at who LeBron
was playing against and be like who
would be playing against guys who were
just good mid-level players and weren't
Hall of Famers that were like all-stars
three times we're like these guys are
actually really good defenders you're
not remember Andre Iguodala right I
thought you know you're not gonna huh I
disagree that you're not gonna be like
oh he was killing Kyle Lowry those demar
derozan games Martha Martha Mary Durant
the Greek freak you're all those guys
baby they gotta win you're gonna member
Kevin Durant you may remember the Greek
freak because they gotta win
championships that's all that you ever
you know love what the Greek freak just
throws LeBron around you ever see that
where they're weird like he box malabo
and Tatum dunk down oh that was sick
what are you doing you know it's a
picture out there of Tatum at like 13
but with LeBron you're saying Yas early
years in the league cuz it's crazy
because all these kids now grew up on
LeBron like it's 20 21 year old kids in
the league you don't say when they were
growing up they were going on watching
LeBron I respect each other
let's hear fighting in these top 10 in
basketball real quick [ __ ] think it'd be
like when Luis Gomez was on I don't
think I could even name ten players yeah
name the old Clippers that we gone oh
what a radix in my top 10
Quentin Richardson Gary smile
Rory's here oh yeah you know he's gonna
be broke he's setting that fat deal and
you know he's bro I think he officially
is I think
that's so sad Tom Chambers I would love
though to go and burn through that money
I would love the opportunity to do oh
like Tyson - well yeah he was like 400
million that's why you saw you saw Don
King recently a dual water at him you
say that that press conference I love
that sure yeah supposedly Don King got
him for 80 you know I'm like walk him
off if you it was that like a Boxing
Hall of Fame induction Rai Rai and Don
King gets announced and he as he walks
by the panel he Pat's Mike Tyson on the
shoulder liked ice is like [ __ ] say hi
to me in and throws water good yeah [ __ ]
him up no that's what I think that's the
only murder that we would not send Mike
Tyson jail for if he murdered Don King
we're like okay you're on probation for
being a meanie you get a mulligan no but
I mean if you [ __ ] off 400 million
though you can't really be mad at the
dude that got you for I would like to
[ __ ] no that's like great life time I
was that broke then like I had a little
bit of money and that is way worse than
having be 400 mil in the hole I would
take 400 mil in the hole over having a
couple bucks in my bank account oh no
without even a thought then would your
Michael Jackson even buying [ __ ] you
everything you know words that can he
pay for it's Michael just like I'll take
four of those and five of them you're
closing the mall down you have to shop
when John comes when Tyson when Don King
Tyson was suing Don King he had to come
up with like an itemized list of what
everything he was you know for charging
him so much money for and on his invoice
had said $100,000 for towels Don King
that's what his invoice so that's he's
like yeah well I mean I you know spend a
hundred thousand dollars on towels on
Mike Tyson my dick every tile in America
a hundred thousand dollars on towels and
Tyson was signing off on that no no
that's once he was like where did all my
money go and then he sued him for all
his money then he legally had to provide
like a you know yeah exactly of like
what all of how he spent a hundred
million dollars of his money right I
mean that's just astronomical
biryeo and I I lived in Vegas jail why
how is he not in jail for taking
somebody's money like that how people
still working with them but it happens
with so much yo it happens so much
though the bezel ax is only like a I
think yeah I get a spanking after cuz
that's how it is for embezzling unless
it's a unless it involves a stock market
I mean you can take advantage of a boy
band for [ __ ] 20 years an athlete and
in athletes no problem but you know
embezzle somebody's money in the stock
market bye-bye bye Felicia
no that's so true cuz I mean the list of
athletes that's gotten [ __ ] by their
agencies is so I mean that's what
happened to Kareem you know saying
that's why he's not just did you uh did
you Instagram or anything i lurk him
every night but I feel bad for him
because he's watching jeopardy and all
of a sudden one of the questions is
comedian Dane Cook's brother stole
millions of dollars from him what is
this crime and it's just like what is
embezzlement that's a weird question
right there's so many other ways to each
vessel has the answer to not ruin
somebody's day exactly that that sounds
if that rings more true to me hey where
are you gonna be oh here it is what's
this is that Jeff Richards who can't
hear how it's him watching it okay yeah
that's not such a weird way to to get to
a bit what is embezzlement I feel how
much did they work him for I think ten
mil just the sound of that is like oh
right right but I mean I don't know the
brother-in-law brother brother his
sister's husband okay brother-in-law
yeah that's [ __ ] I'll be that's how
he's like I'd be mad at a lot of people
yeah yeah mad at her I don't know like I
haven't had that kind of money to say
specifically
with the money I have I keep such a
close eye on my [ __ ] I don't know if I
could get embezzled out of that much
money yo because you ever you have a
certain number to look after like if it
was like I bet you when we look back and
Floyd Mayweather the amount of looting
going on in that guy he probably has no
that's for me I'm not gonna be surprised
right right like if it comes out that
somebody was embezzling Floyd I'm not
gonna be shocked I mean they tried to
rob him constantly yeah like they're
constantly trying to break in his he buy
it like he's so really he's like he has
a so many people in his entourage she's
like a spoon polisher that probably
makes 40 grand a year what do you want
me to do yeah [ __ ] just go polish spoons
here's a bunch 100 I would do that of
course I mean for that rich his personal
comedy on staff comic I'll be a small
warmer for 50 bucks a week he probably
doesn't have that Floyd I'll let you boy
I love they just started his own strip
bar and they just a must our strip
already open strip bar in Vegas your
facts are my favorite thing everything
you know about everybody is always well
he did on his 20 the last 24 7 or
whatever that was in heo it was
constantly broadcast from his own strip
club like he's like alright HBO I'll do
one here 24/7 yeah I made like a year he
opened it up right before he fought
McGregor and then so he was doing his
HBO 24/7 so or whatever they were
calling those they wouldn't interview
him and he'd be like I have to be a must
strip club my first strip club in a long
time cuz a fan of ours of this show yeah
it's like the VIP guy he's like Duke
you're in Vegas you come to Vegas to in
show I'll get a limo for you and set you
up I'm like okay cuz like how does have
taken a limo I just been like don't go
to strip club let's just driver okay you
say that cuz we grew up in now we're in
LA we're like you know that's
disrespectful to women women we can't
treat them like sex objects is a great
thing
and it just monkey DNA takes over like
every woman that is your sweet spot is
walking around there mm-hmm
re how are you I'm great man I'm [ __ ]
great it's a beautiful day I'm [ __ ]
walking around my shirt off all day now
I'm back oh god cast friends Oh were you
gonna be our auditor
I'm gonna be a Manhattan my shows a cobs
the place you went yes week that's San
Francisco not Manhattan that is San
Francisco Thursday Friday Saturday with
Steve Simone a week from Thursday fun
the thermo my favorites try about to
stand closing down huh yeah you know
it's kind of like a it's kinda like a
like a going-away party I said I got
like a mixer with you know a funeral and
a wedding was just like you know
everybody's be but like where's the new
one gonna be nearby I think somewhere
like that but you know it's just like
you got a breakdown on the club about
the comic so the waitress is a comedy
club it's like a part of that and part
of also like just the way the venue is
actually set up a physical space mm-hmm
that sucks
have we mentioned is my body my choice
thing in the background there yeah he's
had it always cuz every time I see it I
want to make fun of it and I remember
he's had it for years
Jason were you gonna be guys I'll be at
the Comedy Store this weekend
belly room Sunday night 10 o'clock show
and I will be of course that skank fest
in the middle of July in Brooklyn so
come to that and a couple quick
announcements
oh I'll be at Six Flags Over Fallujah
I'm doing the active shooter ride and I
big announcement I will not be sticking
my head in doodoo at Nana Nana boo boos
on the fourth of July because they are
closed by the Health Department so
but I know they change to Six Flags Over
Georgia because they had the Confederate
flag I'm just wondering what are the Six
Flags Over Fallujah I don't know it's a
long flight and it sounds cool they were
like um how'd you like to come to a
place that's the bomb and I go I don't
think people really say that anymore and
he goes trust me they say it here they
feel it yeah yeah yeah but they said
everybody there just kills so I think
I'll be fine cream are you gonna be any
date you want to push uh I'ma be a
flapper sometime or at the ice house
some other time follow me on Instagram
what is your Instagram we look up his
Instagram so at Cory Matthews that's
where all the real fun happens you do
have a great Instagram thank you thank
you I try to oh you do you're you're a
repost er of mine I love that man both
of you guys a lot of my followers are
people that follow you guys you sound
like a cult leader letting my follow us
well don't people doing things you ever
watched that Instagram that's a great
one to both there isn't drunk people
doing things very laugh a lot good stuff
right there
hey you you might not laugh at
everything but eventually I will get to
you know I find a lot of this stuff man
first it started off where I was I was
going around finding stuff but now
people send me so much stuff what I find
funny is how that was a good one not to
go on too
hit that one no I don't know how the
where's showing uh sorry yeah I had to
go in I love that the crying Jordan yeah
if that kind of stuff man where do you
think he ends up here's the thing if he
if this Chris Paul and LeBron to the
Lakers thing happens or Paul my shoe is
I mean my suicide note we'll say three
words you know why I'm here as now kill
myself here I him and Paul George you
know saying I can't it's been so many
years I can't be all aboard the Lakers
we're part and LeBron thing right now
if it happens of course I'm a Laker fan
so I'm not gonna not root for him who do
I you know it's gonna be hilarious
you're going I rooted for Dwight Howard
when he had a Laker jersey on you know
Wade Howard didn't even do that so I'm
gonna root for him if it happens but I'm
not pushing the LeBron come to the
Lakers bandwagon this year I'm not
anybody who'd you want boogie cousins
even with the the yeah no it's the
Achilles yeah for a big man that's not a
bad injury you know saying he's gonna be
able to come back from that as a big man
his brain wasn't just kebab he should be
the greatest player play basketball no
he is think of his skill set his tools
he's like an MB him an MB has a similar
skill set you know saying I love that
they all talk [ __ ] - I love it - they
they bring that back that's the ninety
[ __ ] I love them beating down with this
let's all be friendship right we need
more dude that's how the 90s word LeBron
was wanted to do that oh [ __ ] in that
we're all her small do you remember he's
such an [ __ ] now back when he was in
New Orleans when he was on that guy's
team right huh
he would let people crash his house
right but the coaches were like what are
you doing dude you can't do that yeah
well he's like dude I just want to be
friends with everybody and now he's like
[ __ ] you gonna click you can talk in
their voice - in that exact voice no I'm
just say wait it's funny cuz I'm still
like that you know saying I
the Comics League like it's like once
the game starts you my team is my team
and the other team is the other me and
Adam ray used to commit felonies against
each other you would literally commit
felonies do Brett Bourne would come down
the lane I would [ __ ] Rock do dave
taylor ever got away I would just rip
his Jersey up I want to almost whip
David Taylor's Jersey off and I would
just nail shots you had there one game
coked-up I would [ __ ] kill everybody
because we would leave you blatantly
open up but back to lebron t know the
one scenario i heard that i think makes
the best sense yeah it's him to Boston
LeBron yes before
no no but he's going oh he did why he
didn't want him traded cuz it's gonna be
Kyrie is gonna be a sign of trade for
Kyrie or Gordon Hayward so Cleveland get
something LeBron gets the most money
because the way you can get the most
money is signing with Cleveland dude
what kind of hell who I read about clear
Oh No right hey that's that's basketball
though you know say and then LeBron
wouldn't have to leave the east cuz if
he leaves the east I don't know if he's
gonna get to the finals whatever he does
he's gonna have to go to Golden State
and then they still gonna have to get to
Golden State I think with LeBron makes
you think huh here's your problem with
Chris Paul listen you can either make
max or you can win a chip you can't do
both
unless you're LeBron LeBron cam Chris
Paul can't he has too much injury so if
he wants a chip he has to take less
money so that he can sign somebody the
fact that the Houston Rockets had one
point guard on that entire team is why
they lost that series
absolutely cuz when he went down that
was that nobody to fill in but they felt
like it was gonna be able to be hardened
you're saying that's why I didn't have
another point guard cuz they felt like
if something did happen we would just
put the ball in James Harden but that
got injury-prone point guard you should
have a backup and there's a lot of dudes
are pretty good that could play for
[ __ ] minimum wage or whatever try your
chip yeah but where they were at though
they were at that moment what's his name
Durant who dream up
dream on we just not see J my take a pay
cut cuz he wants to stay and go and stay
yeah cuz they would have for Durant they
would have been like look dream on you
gotta go Golden State is a wonderful
team I hate them I love their style ball
so do i but they're an example Oh much
better if they had not signed Durant I
would like them so everyone could root
for them because they're a real team now
they were [ __ ] one of those money
teams same as ever I hate the Yankees is
the reason people hate Golden State now
and they had to [ __ ] everyone loving
them and then because it make you sign
the best player there's throw you over
the top when you were already winning a
championship and it was like you know
what [ __ ] you guys but you know I feel
like did I ask him ha you're up 3-1 I'm
the Golden State Warriors you lose the
next three and then you go play with
them it seems kind of shady as [ __ ] no
it totally does it totally I mean if it
rubbed me the wrong way you know saying
but I've come to the conclusion that
that's how these this generation of
players are you know that's really just
how these dudes are and looking back on
it 20 years from now all we really gonna
be looking at is how many championships
these dudes want that's why I feel like
right now Golden State is writing a
pretty solid legacy as much as I hate it
when we look back on this era we've
really just gonna look at them kicking
everybody's ass you know started the
right Charles Barkley started what
jumpin teetering oh and never got one
though yeah and I love that you know
it's our love when it flops cuz it's
like see stay your ass where you are so
I'm glad that Barkley didn't get one he
taught the gravy train
Carmelo too and he came to the Lakers
table he came so late this year he did
but he's not
it's like he was 15 years in know he did
but all didn't work though right that's
another exact reason they lost that
series because when we went down yeah
later as a backup and it's like that's
fine doesn't matter yeah I mean when you
just when you know you said my Ewing did
you ain't get ya that's not your ring
yeah exactly like Gary Payton has a ring
from our Miami right after the Lakers
yeah remember he I was so fly cuz Mitch
Kupchak who's now Johnny's GM is a
classic sign a dude who's too old but
has a big-name guy and he so the there's
no long Tony Parker's been in the lake
he was murdering the Lakers way back in
the day before the Lakers could get
everything going he was Marty he's
getting Elaine he's too quick for
everybody so they're like hey man let's
sign Gary Payton
he's the glove he's great but they
didn't watch him get murdered by Tony
Parker why was in Seattle and then they
brought him down he said I get murdered
by Tony Parker
he's like nobody's backed me up dude
guys lighten me up a nightstand his
classic Kupchak he signed Steve Nash to
lay he signed Steve Nash any sign Dwight
Howard when they both said Ray don't
want to play there they're like it's a
Lakers waste a couple years I loved it
[ __ ] the Lakers the Lakers the Lakers
are like Pamela Anderson they're like I
was hot in the 90s man don't you want to
[ __ ] this until hey they were hiding -
mm - we'll be back man and that's the
thing I accept this hate that we get
right now when we're down cuz when we're
up we party so [ __ ] hard see that's
the thing we have that kind of pool
though that's a yes I still would want
to put it out there like that but nah
man we'll be back and I think this is
the offseason this is the first
offseason in a long time that we have a
legitimate chance at some of these free
agents for the last few off seasons
particles of the reason that you said
about Mitch Kupchak
no one was gonna legitimately come here
you know saying so we have to give our
money to Maya's golf and dang and
[ __ ] stiffs like that but this year
even if it's not LeBron we're gonna get
a somebody that's gonna move the needle
you know saying a Paul George the boogie
cousins even possibly Kawhi Leonard yo
as I know
Kawhi was like they're [ __ ]
presentation was just comments short no
no we're now no that was Aldridge that's
all did yeah but it's like that's what
they back to the ladies got exposed
where it's like well you got to have a
plan to get back to the championship at
least Philadelphia had a plan you know
that was that was the olders that was
the old regime did the new magical
everything we're gonna get somebody this
offseason you know it's gonna be we're
headed back Korea Korean you're a Laker
fan for real that's not the way you want
to win a championship is getting the
Brawn suddenly no yeah I mean no I
wouldn't love it but I'm not gonna fight
it we got Shaq from Orlando he would
kneecap Steph Curry as he's in the life
just to get a [ __ ] ring yes yes I
mean that's dude that's all professional
sports are about that's it if your team
went to championship if your team
doesn't win the championship your season
was [ __ ]
so that's all whatever it takes yo I'm
on a clipper and a Knick fan my life is
[ __ ]
right before ball Raiders ok so you've
had it well actually were you around for
the last 180 no but I was on the East
Coast room so it goes Raiders then might
I have second teams in everything and
it's rams and bills ok yes see I have
one team in every sport it is all LA
well I mean the Rams are back now they
used to be when they are right no thank
you
I've been to every home game since I've
been back this this upcoming season
should be less right the first real ok
this is a real thing guy defense food
man and our schedule like they put us in
prime time like pretty much
all our games are primetime you got like
it also doesn't hurt that you guys are
in the West Coast there's only four
games going on so you're gonna always be
the primetime West Coast game all right
no but I'm saying by Monday night
Thursday night and then a couple Sunday
nights yeah when we start Monday night
against the Raiders you know what
Oakland I mean come on is that gonna be
is that gonna be a high game or what you
know army it's like we play the Vikings
on what days I might go up for that game
where my jerseys whatever that first
well for something like that you're 18
no no the 10 hey let me know man I got
see gaming an Oakland Stadium before
it's over oh I know this is this the
last season or one more Eric I think it
might be one more I thought was two
seasons yeah quick to get a season a
stadium up is one seat and the RAM
stadium is gonna be great say oh no
absolutely like the NFL's bringing part
of the Hall of Fame they're like the
NFL's bringing their offices because
there's gonna be moving in upon network
there yeah right
ESPN is moving from the Staples Center
to that Stadium
ah everything I'm telling you it's gonna
calmly source moving from the common
stadium the newsstand is gonna be in
that stadium did you see this thing
about speaking to the NFL where the Fox
News which is just terrible your podcast
has more believable stuff in it then
everything on Fox News repeatedly well I
don't know that weird that's almost like
did you stop beating your wife it's like
this weird how do i I would listen I
would listen to tinfoil hat go you know
what maybe there is a werewolf dentist
somewhere before I would believe it
anything on Fox News the Eagles the
Philadelphia Eagles are one of the teams
that never had
anybody kneel during the national anthem
yeah totally proven everybody knows that
and then fox news releases a picture of
all of them kneeling and praying not
during that lanthum but they're just
kneeling and praying I go look man
there's mewling during the national
anthem to back up Trump kicking them out
of because few of them like I don't
wanna go the White House but guess what
people always did that well I'm just
gonna say they were saying that's during
the national anthem first of all three
white guys he already know it's not true
here's my whole thing dude people don't
like this my opinion Trump is such a
[ __ ] genius crazy person like this
national anthem isn't about player city
it's his hatred of NFL and he's just
taking it to office and the world
yep that's why he started the USFL yeah
because you couldn't buy the bills right
recently he tried to get in again
recently he tried to buy the bills okay
right no he first tried to buy the bills
no any tried a USFL sued them and only
won a dollar and then when I think they
were putting together to buy the Texans
he wanted to be a part of the investors
on the Texans and they're like kick
rocks [ __ ] kick rocks [ __ ] without a
t-shirt kick rock [ __ ] oh yes these
guys standing or kneeling right it has
to do with him realizing he's put them
in an impossible situation
I was the kitchen guy at a strip club
I'm the king I'm the kitchen guy at a
strip club I'm dating one of the
strippers yeah he cheats on me I become
the manager of the strip club
guess who shifts are getting the [ __ ]
day shift kick rocks [ __ ] but I mean
that's exactly what happened
he became the President of the United
States and automatically started going
at the NFL do from Amazon yeah I always
wanted that's why would you hire the
fight nannies baby to dance
pole dancing i dapped you know she stim
your headshot see what she could do
I let her shake her diaper around town
Saturday when she has no neck control
she can't sit she can't do any that's
everything Sam's looking for in a woman
and can we give a special shout out to
the guys at dirty sports for taking the
SAT I haven't seen his score yet I don't
think he's gotten it they did a bag of
that yeah guys there's a good chance
next Oh next week I'll be shoving a hot
dog got my BA are you yeah you're
already in the second week of July no
someone has to do that take the SAT one
together no I'm gonna do it Sam's like I
decided I'm doing it next week so I'm
doing it I'm gonna get a [ __ ] colonic
and an enema clean out the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] cage I'm I have this porn star
come and shove a hot dog up my butt a
frozen one is it gonna be frozen I got
thrown your real life for sex what do
you think a hot dog could be anything
more in case it breaks off you can you
talk more about I don't think it's
worried about getting hot dog I'm trying
to enjoy the hot dog up my ass boom
throw it up there I chosen is worse but
guys always say that that sounds more no
it's not gonna be frozen it's gonna be a
regular hot dog with a lot of guys say
like oh but if it's all slap your ass
my nanny hey Johnny watch I would love
to watch it's not gonna be video no
video I'm gonna run for mayor someday
too late yo this is all because you're
worried about your point pushing 50 30
years of interviewing strippers and
hookers that looks like a good one we
used to use that hot dog and three of
those in my eyes I want you to the pun
on it what about the bunny you're gonna
go bun or no bun no bunless bunless I
got a little big pretzel roll button at
B mama go put a condom morning oh she
will - I'm so honored to watch I'll
think about it when I go to bed at night
you know that's what ron jeremy put
payton st. Claire that doesn't sound
like a poor name at all yeah it's her no
she's not sure
oh she's no okay she has a nightmare
before christmas tattoo I approve
[Laughter]
what'd he say it's a baby tattoos those
can't all be her I think those are
different people are gonna say yeah
she's not very good when you like look
of a porn sorry everything comes out
right quick links to videos are already
Wikipedia Instagram
I like I complimented her tattoos
already I felt bad at the one picture on
Google bottom on let's see if we can get
coffee - are you gonna walk off now like
I've had it you're clean out the garbage
they get it after no before cuz I don't
want to stink
but they're gonna have hot dog particles
in your ass so we'll do it when you're
Yuki do yours when you're here I'm do my
next friends before skank fest you're
going out there first
I'm getting it done before skank fest
you're coming here right before it's
confessing and going back and then we
can talk about it at skiing fest dude
next week
Sam is ready just to be difficult Sam's
gonna stick to doing he might do it
twice if you like it you'll do it
spanish fly and then sit on a couple
dogs you know typical Tuesday morning
Tuesday morning did you guys see this
what this sounds awesome if they do this
from Union Station downtown to Dodger
Stadium that a gondola oh yeah I heard
about that Johnny look this up it looks
badass yeah that would be the [ __ ] I
mean it just goes right above all the
traffic along sunset oh my thing is
always how long is that gonna take to be
put in place I'm always like they said
they'll be done by Thursday Oh
that was this crazy guy on my street
here's the thing here's thing brah brah
is that we have subway systems we have a
ton of them and they moved it all the
way to Santa Monica and no one uses it
because that's where I am on the west
side is way back in like the 40s we had
a subway system in LA yeah and they
won't use it is that wrong I mean they
gotta get rid of all the lizard people
that live down there you know yeah
that's what they're talking about 5,000
fans an hour that's it right there looks
doe look at that take that from downtown
right to Dodger Stadium yes see that's
it get that going we get all over the
[ __ ] city down Dodger Stadium is not
that far though so it's gonna be a ton
of money for not that big of a distance
money go back what they say about Frank
McCourt
he owns it oh dude what about him
they're saying he originally pitched
that got it going and then all that
[ __ ] happen and now they're trying
to revisit his old idea basically do you
remember how crazy his wife was 20 22 so
they want it done by the Olympics is
there gonna be fun oh I'd love to go see
boxing it's gonna be the [ __ ] basketball
obviously boxing's always 84 84 was the
last time I got that far Lewis's heyday
right right Russia also refused to come
here because of the Cold War yeah so we
just mopped up every metal now we did be
with a [ __ ] yeah I remember I went to a
soccer match at the Rose Bowl I don't
even remember what two teams it was but
it was an Olympic soccer match you know
saying that that year yeah I was still
in the womb I would do that [ __ ] hey
2022 is gonna be the
yeah well half of these people on the
show will be dead by all the trains all
the trains will all be connected by then
and if they have that gondola that'd be
dope yeah miss you know it's gonna be a
lot of other [ __ ] too
yeah we won the medal count that year
look we swap I know exactly
that was the year the Simpsons even did
a China this is before they decide to
try Koran or they were in it they
weren't ROI yet though they were like
okay we must win everything see West
Germany still you know oh yeah [ __ ] West
Germany they were there's East Germany's
even there they didn't they didn't medal
Russia for life right big life it guys
ah the World Cup is coming up and you
know what that means
lots of betting go to bat D as I bet the
aside for everybody needs that's right
go to bet DSi use the promo code punch
25 and you will get [ __ ] tons you get
$20 bag get 25 35 been cash and you'll
be able to bet on the World Cup I'm
excited you're excited when does that
start
yeah starts in two days
that'd be a great thing about perfect
timing too because basketball
I mean basketball sended hockey
descended you know baseball still hasn't
heated up but what if that was part of
the plan to like the branches and this
[ __ ] place the World Cup about space
Thursday I'm excited dude and you I bend
the UFC fights I got every fight right
except for one RDA right yep remember I
thought like hey how's your vet and
you're like I forgot you did yeah better
than all five and he missed it by one
that's always - I'm like I want to be
there when you get it yeah a couple
times though no I have draw I hit a draw
yeah cuz I remember when you posted that
one I think though you should I say soul
time you should also win if you get them
all wrong
there's some places that you can't do
that yeah
are some places that have that as what
salary if bingo does you get zero to ten
you win I like a lot of money especially
during Super Bowl time they have that
way to a dad that's actually hard to do
that it is hard to do that there's I've
done it before if you're welcome losers
you could do like a 10 team parlay in
the NFL and which pays out great if you
hit it but it pays out like one third of
what you would hit if you did you go
over ten right which is just as hard to
do no it really is usually you're gonna
get at least two right even if you're
just blind picking absolutely yeah yeah
yeah
I mean Sam's dog probably you know rent
randomly get two or three right sweating
bucks yeah dude
so the United States is not in the World
Cup who does that make you rooting for
Armenia
I gotta go with either one I think
Armenians would like their soccer team
would have capes that's crazy the US
isn't in it this year like a bunch of
vampires run around kicking a ball and
[ __ ] Vladimir pass me the ball I know no
it's not because we throwing crazy
against Russia do you think they want us
there oh yeah that's true that would
have been crazier [ __ ] about there were
some shady roughing when it came to that
last game about us getting in about
Italy to make it okay notable
Netherland they wanted a couple years a
couple World Cups ago I think so you're
not gonna watch well who the hell do you
root for I mean you kind of root against
like dominant teams like put the
Brazilians and like teams you're like
God I don't want France doing it again I
don't want Brazil to win it again right
hot chicks I'm like because this is a
hot chick that be at those games
Russians look at that that's what that's
what I love about stills got it
plus they got the hot shemales am i
right Johnny why Johnny has some hot
ones too yo Spain but they do have some
shows over there smoke shows where do
you select a pope I'd like to poke her
hunter yes you are we could her yeah
thanks just set me down there as re hand
slides down dude I bet you they have a
power rake the hot chicks of the World
Cup look if they have that power rank
two hot chicks of the World Cup hmm they
got him throughout the years right the
change depending on what cups every four
years right or two four years that's
when the Olympics was better when it was
every four years they decided to make it
every two years no it is
oh they Spade will the winter and summer
alternate yeah there should be one year
it would be winter and much bigger than
if they had to look
her if they had winter and summer in the
same year you mean yeah so it's just a
solid year I'm in pickle I'm German
hello that's Mexico yeah that's like
she's done a ton of coke am i right how
much coke is that chick with that tiny
nose oh she's got the big teeth that I
like somebody's got some chiapas teeth
or too big triple e wants to [ __ ] the
masks Marsh chicks are you guys think
about tio refusing to go to the home
alright loves it cuz that's a move you
would pull can we all pick a team and
root for them I mean I the world will
but I reserve the right once it starts
and I start liking certain players away
certain team to play because I'll find
an underdog that I want to brutal soon
ok Denmark I'm gonna root for Denmark
that's why I like you go pick who has no
work ok let's go take people and Mike
relax alright ok Raja you might want to
root for the Russian team man ok ok I'm
right down a couple maybes here
ok definite relation
okay the still does have some smoke
shows yeah go Brazil I'm gonna change it
Brazil just because of that reason
Wow the Nexen trans that's what I'm
going for
so give me the Brazil Sam's really
thinking outside of his normal comfort
zone oh I think I'm going Sweden I go
Germany Germany I just saved again
Germany Germany's good i'ma go Germany
I'm final decision definite tunisia i
tunisia by tunisia
I might go England to one lesson why is
Japan bad I know they have tiny legs
well I want you were rooting for Japan
then oh they're all the size of their
daughter really all the size your
daughter but they can hold their head up
portugal man god okay I've I have five
teams that I like Portugal Denmark
Brazil Sweden Germany in England I'm
just that I'm gonna let those five teams
simmer and then I'm gonna see what pops
up in what I like
Thursday a two day new days baby it goes
to like 2050 it'll feel like that so
what's your team I don't know I picked
five and I'm gonna see how the first
round goes I'm gonna see which ones I
like that switch teams four times your
team sure my 15 so that's a good team a
month who do you have Russia Russia okay
you have two pair
yeah the 14th to the fitting I'm rolling
with Portugal Portugal yeah that's for
sure
Johnny got team Portugal re the United
States are not in each other you can't
be in stop with your North Carolina
nationalism the Netherlands either I
don't think
Oh Denmark he said different thoughts
Cardinals are in it can't pick up is
Denmark in it I'm going Poland they're
gonna score all their goals in Rome go
if Denmark is in it I'm a roofer DeMar
I'm going England what what am i writing
down I mean this is on audio will be
able to easily find it
no like will bother somebody will be
like can you get it back to us but none
of us look it up Oh Denmark isn't it
there the bottom of Group C Denmark sit
re-pick I'm Rome Adel mark
Kareem's Denmark on the upside mr yeah
oh that's so nice like that
you say oh that's so nice yes first guy
thank you for you he doesn't know any
actual black people buddy who you are
the clothes he knows me he knows me are
he's going Russia cuz he loves bad oh
that's so nice sorry God is going good
old US of a Johnny
Piketty Johnny cannot win with that okay
he goes English I already picked England
okay Johnny doesn't want to prep it just
go going or Morocco Egypt
yes what is the breaking news Ari
Russia has just announced that they had
[Laughter]
what are you do I having Egypt go Iran
or Morocco gone is out I'm noticing a
pattern
all yours go gotta go a less black
country Oh God no they're now counters
out Canada
Ghana's not in it Ghana's not about
Morocco that's a good pick
Aaron what about you st. Louis Cardinals
I got in Poland Poland oh that's right
okay
Poland that's I feel like it goes I
don't know what the winner gets but it
will be fun winner gets a hot dog bun in
their ass no I just a bun that's where
you tuck it in with a broom handle oh
yes infection it's a winner
that's a winner you don't want to know
what you lose I hear we're adding my
breast milk to the bag of butts that one
of you has to drink it
how much like a gallon I know sounds
like please can I have pumps them out
for there's these like tubes that are
like three ounces that I do pretty I do
some shots shots for real can I ask you
a question if we can do this yes
what are you breast milk into bottles
but like squeezable bottles and then
have your baby in the middle and then
we'll just act like we're [ __ ]
[ __ ] all over your baby but it should
be breast milk and just bathing it down
that I don't like that I think it's
wrong because he just wants to stick her
baby on a goddamn someone that's not
creepy like that's at least one person
will go to jail yeah before the end of
this episode
breaking news it's a lot he said it's
allowed when I'm super engorged to like
my nipples do sprayer in the face and I
always feel really bad about that
because it is like you probably now
starting some weird [ __ ] that we're not
gonna know about for about 18 years she
does know she's the one that takes her
mouth off and I'm like I have to wipe
her face off and then style shower can
you not take your mouth off the [ __ ]
take out the goddamn trash
I don't care your head bobbles like I
[ __ ] we were talking about Terrell
Owens uh not going to go to the refusing
to go after complaining for many years
are not getting inducted well no that's
the thing though it hasn't really been
many years it was only like three three
three
there's honest percent out that waited
ten years to get me he got it on his
third I believe and they went you know
saying they went this dude that got held
out way longer than this is like a one
if it made him traumatize if you know
his story like dad know if they made it
like a block away wouldn't even
recognize him right if they made him
wait ten years I guarantee you'd have a
different containers mouth over it but I
just this is a once in the light I gave
the [ __ ] too quick you know me like I
just feel like he really needs to
rethink this [ __ ] yo coz Phi years ago
or I guarantee you people are going to
you gotta go this you have this open I
don't care how managing prior
relationship with the community dude say
something in your support community if
nothing else say something in your
speech yeah all gamers you know I mean
if you if you're mad go there and say a
crazy speed too but you gotta [ __ ]
show up y'all right you don't five years
after they're not gonna let you come
back and say okay I changed my mind let
me get my jacket there
gotta go get your [ __ ] tacky yo
that's it like yeah or don't speak you
don't have a pulse make me a jacket show
up an uber comes up exactly five stars
protein in water and your and your bus
yeah this you don't look like they never
look like him they never look like him
do i ah I think he's being an idiot I
think it's really dumb I mean he's being
him I don't know is this him to not go
to the high note go but just like to do
something [ __ ] interesting it's like
not everybody's talking about him as the
guy in this class everybody's talking
about it why me I feel like it was gonna
be that way anyway though was he not
gonna be the dude you talked about after
all all his antics yeah but you could
have I think he could still have the
antics and show up to this thing and and
and make it I would say controversial
but uh go viral
take my stache yeah the crazy thing
though he's still freaking athletic you
know like he posted himself on Instagram
running like a five like realize his
hands just at the end it was just he
couldn't catch anything that's why
that's why I ended up getting drop ya
know that that makes sense
that's le face is being gay uh who was
the quarterback for San Francisco oh oh
who Garcia yeah remember Garcia talk and
I remember before Madden and
what's-his-face used called games before
they retired Oh imagine summer Oh
so remember summer I'll talk about like
talking to him you wouldn't know he was
a football player you don't give the mm
lifts speeds like we just like to push
the ball down this down the field really
female ever play made mini hot play man
he's like you know she pegged him in
there as Jeff I see is like listen look
at that how long do you have to live in
LA before you see gay face anybody well
I mean he was the quarterback at a 49ers
come on we weren't listen
our tight ends are I mean they know
harder get football for real the gay
guys football is that Jacksonville
defender the corner Thank You
whatever-his-name-is
gaming Ramsey Galen Ramsey interviews is
not it's not even a question
no are you serious no yeah but you know
supposedly Antonia Brown talks it to him
on the feel about that like that's why
they're they literally fought on the
field
hold on do an interview or this guy's
gay okay the best done you know as Galen
Ramsey Nate and Russell Westbrook has
gay face oh for sure sharp chance up to
go up go up right there no over where
the right now down one more yeah well I
think that was I think the one up here
that looks like they everybody outside
of donut time right you wanna hire
[Music]
here's where tio here's where Trello ins
is [ __ ] the Falcons he has been
training with Julio all summer Terrell
Owens and never a problem sir I mean
Julio's never been a problem guess she's
holding out now three years left it
you know tio while they're working out
is just like man you can't let the
[ __ ] treat you like that you
can't let you know blah blah baby bib
shut up shut the [ __ ] up
we just ran that four or five no Wayne
on when your quarterback gets so much
money you'll be like why is he in all
that money you know one thing Julio
Jones can't do play kickball
yeah oh wow no yeah I probably throw
whenever these dudes throw the first
pitch out I might do some of them yeah
you're like [ __ ] John Wall
oh yeah he was terrible it's the NBA
players that are bad at it yeah what 50
was bad too he's a rapper
dude yeah I could get ordained tweet was
so [ __ ] funny
what was it any time a celebrity dies I
go to arias Twitter first Dave tears
also money what a great career you have
where you literally can say anything you
want and everyone's like I know oh my
god these comedians I can't re Jeff's
like let's go you wouldn't say about
someone you love and I was like reporter
my roughly mate wait please but here it
is here is Julio Jones many went by what
is Lex Luthor doing here morgue a fence
is this the gay sports network this is
uh here we go
oh my god seriously how do you miss and
kick my can dude check out a strike a
kickball Charles Barkley's golf swing at
least Charles Barkley made contact but
it looks like an earthquake happens on
his backswing right but he hits the ball
I've never seen a strike in kickball I
mean you're telling me this guy never
was like dead [ __ ] got a strike
in kick ball one strike in year out it's
no dish is this for charity or something
like why does this exist well he plays
golf
oh yeah he plays golf and he's that bad
yeah cuz I'm hoping it was like burn
money for the children this is a he goes
out a lot it has the weirdest drug why
does he stop
because she's crazy buddy my life that
he says what's that one he makes contact
though yo dude I'm try god I was not a
poet behind him my dad did that once
how do I get behind I like her I like
how he said that um hey our brother off
clothes before man oh me too
that's just not easy oh it looks he's
making contact he said the next person
that comes up to him and said ask him
who's better LeBron or Michael he's
gonna slap him in the face no matter who
it is I don't believe that the
comparison is even LeBron and Jordan now
how did he just jump past Kobe how come
there's no Jordan LeBron and Kobe
conversation that's what it should be no
one should be talking about Jordan and
LeBron I would take Tim Duncan over Kobe
every time a thousand times
would you take that's what you should do
right that's to be a new swing yeah
magic means so like your your swing at
golf is notoriously so bad that there
are multiple compilation videos [ __ ]
hitting a ball behind you and [ __ ] why
don't we uh why don't we put
cheerleaders in the Hall of Fame oh gosh
where do we begin because no one gives a
[ __ ] about them other than you who would
name me one goddamn Cheerilee my name
yeah does that mean pavani we just
approved the point because no one can
name the Rams the Rams have Leo do
leaders this year oh I know
I didn't I didn't I was not on board
here I can't love it I'm not on board
with that though so the the the Clippers
one time he had this one guy you know
they always had the guys hyping up
they'd one dude one video he did he got
boots so bad they never saw him back
so together Los Angeles we have to boo
these mail chillers to the point they
Anthony Bourdain it anybody right Aaron
are you write you write that joke would
kill Aaron told me to do that joke it
was like doing making port make it a
verb he there they go that's them two on
the right over one more no way those are
the new male RAM cheerleaders yeah yes
they just made it this year he's so mad
he's standing everybody Sam's about yeah
two dudes yeah they made it right that
is not a straight man that's the great
guy straightest block look at that smile
he said who is this for oh my gosh these
guys are straight this episode should be
called I was there I don't even know
what game that is but I was there busy
talking heads episode where no one knows
we're watching you didn't didn't Ari
but this is the season to have them no
but then you give him a Bosch they're
not trading him over for the new stadium
so I really got him so I can hunt for
the new stadium oh good thing you got a
dart oh the right to buy oh right but
still this season's gonna be off the
hook
ticket barely but I can't afford yeah no
licenses to be able to buy them yeah
that's so dumb they do that so Grady
are you sure crying cuz he lost his
tickets but that pay that pays for the
stadium no that's how it can be publicly
is it no public money
hey are you for this season though you
should renew do just give me your
tickets dude dude you couldn't even sell
your scalper tickets for the playoffs
but this season I know but this season's
gonna be different yo but also this
season we're gonna be more Hollywood
we're soon to leave the Chargers will
never get LA yeah no but there will be a
good second no they sustain the charges
today they'll be good second time no I
should've I agree
no what you're not but it's over for
that they're going to Vegas and that's a
great man
that's a great landing spot for me
that's a great landing spot I would even
go to some games for a weekend in Vegas
yeah everybody no I don't have a
secondary team you know I don't but I
carbage day I can rule for them though
like I don't you know I'm saying it's
some teams I just can't rule for the
Raiders aren't on that list the Chargers
aren't either like if you know yeah
right there Ari's giving the pulse of LA
even though he hasn't lived here for
years like the well yeah is this what
you're hearing on the streets like two
weeks bitching about it
never hangs out are you bitching about
it now okay can you only got breaking
news Ferrari from Ari Shaffir Ari here
fight nanny yes has put breast milk into
oatmeal and served it to Jeff Dennis
without him knowing
yep I knew that not without him knowing
I made myself oatmeal and Jeff likes to
eat my food when I'm doing stuff and I
always come and catch him eating my food
or I come back and it's half-eaten and
he's like what's wrong with your oatmeal
it's disgusting and I said oh I ran out
of milk so I use something oh yeah yeah
it tasted to me tasted like maple and
brown sugar and breast milk is sweet
that's babies like it breast milk to me
tastes like camel come okay who let you
touch their breast I get a camel and
suck him off he was really grossed out
he's like he's like breast milk is
disgusting oh my Ari
did you watch 225 did you guys already
talked about that no is Ari happy that
Ronda is in the Hall of Fame now do you
think cheerleader Hall of Fame make the
rules up oh she did for female sports
but like guys 6 & 2 I knew he'd be so
right shall we fight eight times forget
that ten years later
stop fighting who is who is the worst
person in the you in the UFC Hall of
Fame Ronda Rousey or Stephan Bonnar
well Stephan Bonnar did the same [ __ ]
Rana did he he was in that fight one
fight that brought the UFC into the
mainstream hmm right inverse well that's
worth something what is this yeah it's
not even so much accomplishments as much
as it is thanks for the money yeah Conor
should be in already Conor should be on
already yeah John should be in you know
definitely should be in
who's that big guy from the WWF or what
uh brock lesnar definitely hall of fame
with three fights no yeah that's
retailer why are they putting around to
them that's creepy cuz she made him a
shitload of money and they don't know
what to do with her now yeah she's fine
she's in the WWE
yeah but they're not making money on
that she's gonna cry if she wasn't in
this abyss you know she stinks I've
heard that from other people too Ari she
plays by the Schumer rules where she
shouldn't like the deals just read does
it based not on fairness but just like I
get this yeah yeah I mean that's a good
way of negotiation yeah yeah I want that
kind of let's agree on this but if it
changes i'ma get whatever I want it goes
it goes without saying that not good
like I don't think she's gonna be good
in the UFC I don't think she can act
her only faces did somebody fart yeah I
don't fart i boards record is better
than Rhonda's right Rhonda will be a
cyborg will be in the UFC Hall of Fame
doesn't it go without saying that uh CM
Punk is done I thought he was so good
she broken him yeah what during the live
fight on the palm I could beat him I
think he said I could be too much sir
actually I'm not sure I just saw they
saw the clip that would be a fight I'd
like to see or him and Floyd go get in
Floyd
no punking floors all that they could
make that hair that they talked about
who would watch that I wouldn't watch
that people would watch that yo you
watch a fifty-year-old Floyd Mayweather
and a 47 year old CM Punk yes people hug
each other for 12 rounds huh no us I'd
rather watch mail cheer wouldn't be 12
rounds UFC oh yeah UFC they both have
their market too
except for sure oh no a bunch of people
would they've talked about that yo punk
and Floyd cuz floors been putting out
there he's coming to he's not coming
he's putting that out there yo shot
Evans Hall of Fame and I believe he just
retired correct Oh knocked out I mean
he's definitely done but I believe
you're retired
yeah they he's all of Fame that's all of
Fame to me that's all that's all thing
yeah I'm married
those are the merit Hall of Famers what
I recognize that's a Hall of Fame
but the Ronda Rousey is gonna be the
firefighter from Indiana
that was a good UFC fighter do you guys
remember that you know talking about he
pays a firefighter can you put it in UFC
fighter fire UFC fighter firefighter
Indiana because this guy's interesting
do because he had more like by the
Knights than anybody ever he had more
fighter night fights anybody UFC I mean
that's a stat I mean how many what was
his final record you know so and then
you have Joel on Zoho those critics
Friday night's one knockout of the
nights at 7:00 yeah so whoa Joe Lonzo
like he had a ton of those man what is
he 31 and 18 it's a lot of lost but 31
wins there's a lot of wins and I feel
like in the UFC and MMA in general it's
kind of hard to count people down for
their losses
everyone's gonna [ __ ] find a person
everyone's gonna 50 you know in the UFC
at all or now that a gun or even war
without a gun ooh all right you got
breaking news get them goddamn sound
effect going bro we got breaking news
all right just about that
delante wilder agreed two of the terms
with Joshua Joshua Joshua never heard of
any of those people a nice it's not a
big deal if it delante wildlife shows up
if Deontay Wilder shows up no deal yet
now it's on the other side he said he
agreed to the terms ari said it but the
internet saying no Ari has a special I
said what I said what you said the deal
was made I think it says the deal should
be done within the month
yeah what was the breaking news you just
broke I broke it well he look up delante
wobbler cuz that's the one that he said
you're [ __ ] dead versus Joshua Joshua
Joshua that's who he was fighting see
that fine oh that's a fight that has to
be made do you want to go to hot chicks
fighting yes you wanna go I got invited
this Thursday the hot chicks fighting at
downtown Spearmint Rhino is a boxing uh
dress it's like MMA hot chicks porn
stars and strippers they all fight each
other if they got male cheerleaders I
don't often the crowd you're really how
you doing are you gonna finish that
nachos no you're not did you make this
up did you dream of my Slayer came to
our big successful UFC 225 live viewing
party Mickey golf was there to break
down the sand as you only thought I was
the only person to beat him in the UFC
both of those guys beat my Jackson to
him he'd be Mike Jackson after he beat
and Punk so both both cousin yeah he'd
be both way can I get in there to fight
these [ __ ]
no can I go in there fight these [ __ ]
off in the crowd they said was it the
same guy that told you delante wobbler
is gonna fight Joshua Joshua Joshua
yeah dude there are babies allowed
babies babies come from we should get
him you should get your little girl in
the playground and pound that's what I
rent is easy what I meant can I bring
your playpen the kids can fight in you
know I mean yeah dude this are from
Matt's lair and he does play by play and
yeah berry carrots is coming yeah that's
what it is
Kyle go up go up go up go up there it is
right there
Caliente cage rage so in the desert no
it's any uh games and games dog Oh
where the hell's games and games it's
downtown but like you said they're like
everybody knows where Dave Van Nuys Van
Nuys that's where dreams come true and
pay nice it's great yeah Sam I went to
my six week follow-up appointment and
there was a pregnant girl in a crop top
and I immediately thought of you and
would you be into this yes did she have
she loved pregnant should she have Jim
Carrey's teeth from [ __ ] guys just
like I I think I got a picture from my
friend no and this girl's just so
confident in her crop top and huge belly
and I was like that is that was somebody
feeding her carrots with her giant horse
teeth so he didn't look at her Ari
Sam smelled the waitress the waitress at
Sycamore tavern he asked to smell her
armpits which waitress the one that had
a little Poochie belly yes I could see
that then did she let him yes and she
said smells like cocoa butter
that's a form of sexual harassment right
like I think he forgets he's almost 50 a
lot of times in he's in public like we
haven't gotten our bill yet like cocoa
butter which is not a bad smell at all
no dude I said cuz he look and I smell
yours and I was like I don't smell like
come down from what you just smell all
right did you watch 225 no what were you
doing Saturday this was this past
Saturday I was I was in Washington DC
during shows no way yeah
are you a capitals guy congratulations
then sir thank you where were you for it
did you watch it what do you mean what
the [ __ ] last game I watched and it
was [ __ ] great they won it was
[ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] Washington I was there for Game
three in Washington proper game for
excuse me did you play but I watched my
dad I'm okay when pians because we're
thinking about going down for a thousand
bucks each I'm like yeah no they'll pay
that on the East Coast that was their
first one right uh-huh
first one in like people it's almost 50
years that's a mistake me I was born
yummers one so forty three years before
they did when a game is the first four
games they wanted a Stanley cook and
then they were playing Vegas
this is their first I'm glad they didn't
win damn I mean that's why I hate when a
new team does just straight-up great has
a new team ever wanted their first year
in any sport I don't think so
marijuana knock your first year DC
United they won the whole thing their
first year but wasn't that the whole
league's first year everybody's first
year there but yeah well Carolina and
Jacksonville men when they both became
new NFL franchises they did good they
got to like NFC and
championship game first year no say it's
Oh Marlon yeah Mullins might have been
good I don't get to but they didn't win
it their first year now Marlins was five
years yeah that's still crazy I'm in
back this first year and they literally
were put together how you normally put
together team where you just picking up
spare parts from every other team yeah
usually that's not a championship team
that's how to open Michael Jordan's got
started Johnny yeah these are open
Michael Jordan jerseys at oh that's
great that's great Miami Heat were the
fastest which was how long okay that's
pretty damn quick oh yeah oh yeah what
about to win a championship
yeah the Diamondback breaking the news
yeah it's got to be talking about Casper
says [ __ ] yeah creme Matthews Denmark
all the way me he says he lost his
virginity to a sister and because
there's no black people where he's from
he doesn't realize you're supposed to
put an A at the end so it's a sister not
your sister but he tried so he
apparently [ __ ] his sister and he lost
his virginity Thank You Casper news yeah
I think this was the farthest of first
team first-year team has ever got of
course
yeah no that's what we were saying they
were trying to figure it out but no
other in any sport all right I think the
Jags and the Panthers came close and we
said yeah but not their first year
you're gonna win it either Vegas would
have gone bankrupt they said like 10
grand to everybody right but even if you
had bet them to get to the finals that
before the season was like at least
probably a hundred to one yeah I mean
dude
this is their first season no I
guarantee use way more than 101 okay
right about 350 the wall I can go for
500 the one no I can go for that because
I mean you're literally making a new
team of no chemists a new team with no
chemistry whatsoever it's got to be a
head to be with four parts
you owe me Lulu you're taking players
that know oh he's like the junk Voltron
put together and just start kicking
everybody sound right take a band name -
hi Voltron to get billing 200 - wine ok
200 whoa
it must have been a thousand to one but
they're still though the last one right
though that was before the season yeah
that's what I mean yeah so they had the
the most disparaging odds to make it
yeah yeah that was like a billion to one
to maybe put ten bucks on that you went
to your grand right yeah well that's
good I'd [ __ ] gambling is always a
hindsight and they came through though
like that'sthat's a unbelievable story
that'll be a movie yeah let's get the
movie by the way the golden knights by
far had the biggest hot porn star
following like I wonder where that was
going
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah cuz all the porn
stars moved to Vegas and they all go the
gold night games have you been to a
hockey game I went to a Kings game a
while back this is when they still were
the purple and gold and played at the
forum
hockey's the best line la oh no no the
worst is football by far you see oh oh I
don't think football is no I live to a
power ranking right now let me see
hockey baseball basketball for what lies
best live baseball so boring sorry me
I can easily watch baseball on TV more
than live high you're our creme Matthews
the number one Instagram account on
Instagram yeah yeah hey I'm seven seven
three hello
we'd love to talk about the Yankees no
we don't we always pass re these
questions kind of for you when your
lovely Michelle wolf just answer the
goddamn Yankee question Ari
[Laughter]
that wasn't a very convincing answer ari
look it right in the camera and say that
you guys don't hook up without smiling
for anything why they always a 5-second
laugh before you you can't get in you
can't even say it
look that's a good cause her vagina
takes like months up collar of the year
so far
how old is Michelle wolf she looks like
a rock doesn't share nice oh no I think
she's great
that's what she had a math problem huh
that's when she went to a premieres no
down one down down down there we go that
one for sure
the heavier spike go up ah go up right
there now you win is Carrot Top to our
movie premier table look at already get
offended we're making previs to friends
look at that so upset that's his little
dime piece that's a little sad piece I
love her down there that's what she's in
ours kitchen right now Oh me comedy
central one oh yeah Pat is like I love
children's theater she's
[Music]
hey Johnny go down a little bit I got a
good joke right there in a red that's
little dolphin Fanny right there quiet
even here crying off-screen can't
believe Ari would left him let us make
fun of his girlfriend alright give that
a - oh is that her doing her show I
don't know oh well guys I'll cream give
it your shout real quick what is your
Instagram at Kareem Matthew's one more
time more time yeah yeah yeah I'm on
Instagram on Facebook what is this
alright dude you're creeping everybody
out what a great show right nanny you
what our ego that I forgot about earlier
show he would donate a bunch of money to
Sick Children & Children's Hospital if
you ran a marathon and it turns out he
never had any intention of doing that
they were kind of counting on that money
because he's really adamant about it but
I guess he was just doing it to get
Instagram followers which is awful to me
so I heard a fund to raise the money
that he promised so these kids don't
have to die without toys so you go to go
funky comm slash evil Bert you can even
get five dollars it's five dollars more
than [ __ ] awful Bert Gabe so I'm just
trying to like how about least
acknowledge thanks for disappointed at
Bert's awful behavior that Bert one sick
children to die and says who created
this page I wonder re I will donate
money you know if you're a nice guy you
know you're doing it for wrong [ __ ]
reasons so I know it's weird to hear
children yeah you're so stupid
[Laughter]
ralphie so much what else what else what
else did we learn today our he's [ __ ]
a dolphin
well guys great show anybody want push
anything else I would like to prefer got
one of our new sponsors the newest
sponsor of punch-drunk is LeBron James
everybody yeah Bron James all right dude
guys thanks tune in we'll see you next
week I'm probably gonna shove a hot dog
off my butt I'll talk to you guys soon
bye Seymour something he's getting off
the phone okay